we have the oh geez it's just an
unbelievable overwhelming experience
early two-thousands fashion some of the
worst fashion faux pas and a first time
for literally everything I'm not here to
make friends this is your the bachelor
greatest seasons ever Episode five two
seasons in one episode recap grab your
glasses it's time for roses then Rosie
hey everybody it's me Lauren Zima in an
oversized blaze make it work oh hi you
guys how are you it's so good to see
everyone we are here to discuss The
Bachelor greatest seasons ever
episode 5 where we got both The Bachelor
Lee first season and The Bachelorette
as season and number one and in honor of
all of the amazing ill-fitting Ryan
Sutter in a bucket hat I guess what
we're gonna call zebra-print and I think
I was swimming in my dad's suit in style
then I guess but really funny now outfit
moments I'm wearing this here he is The
Bachelor so The Bachelor began in 2002
and we had Alex Michelle the first
bachelor and Chris Harrison the first
and only bachelor host questionable
suits
[Music]
I'm literally right now wearing Chris
Harrison's jacket you guys because I
kind of thought it would be like
oversized it'll be like really funny all
I have to say it's like actually kind of
a bit chic tomorrow's pose you have to
like hunch for no reason crushed it so
right off the bat everybody let's pour
our wine and today I actually went with
a red because I thought if we are going
back and going old-school we got to
drink something that is just red like a
rose mm-hmm I've also gone with a very
small glass because I just can't seem to
stop spilling
[Music]
Oh God and so I'm getting a very large
base and a low center of gravity and
that's that's what I'm going with
because even though my apartments quite
bare the few items that I do have are
incredibly light in color so gosh I'm
asking for it with the red though aren't
I here we go and I'm wearing a little
turtleneck the only one I could find for
Miss Trista Sutter the og Bachelorette
because we also did her season on this
episode and she wore a lot of
turtlenecks now we are all in the early
two-thousands vibes so JC and Christine
have joined me Christine working a crop
top working a creme tear working a gold
hoop JC who in a very boy band friendly
hoodie and he went ahead and threw on
the blazer - you know what you guys have
you want if you're feeling festive and
because we're quarantined and what the
else are we doing please go put on some
kind of early two-thousands outfit post
it on your Instagram story I will share
it let's go back in time together
because the presents weird you know so
let's go back Cheers
what did you think of this episode of
The Bachelor greatest seasons ever what
struck me about it was that I was
expecting to watch it and think wow the
show's changed so much I seen same-same
I was shocked to find out how many of
the staples we love about bachelor and
bachelorette now we're literally there
from the beginning so in the early
two-thousands words of Hilary Duff let's
go back back to the beginning
[Music]
so everybody the franchise is come and
clean let's get to it
now we are going to discuss all of the
ways that the show is actually
incredibly similar but first there's one
major way that it was major lady friends
and I didn't even know about it
we're not at the bachelor mansion this
is where you'll be living for the next
six weeks this place the driveways not
wet there are some wet areas but it just
looks like big just water those plants
it doesn't look very intentional this is
messy we think it is the ultimate
bachelor pad Chris Harris have called it
the ultimate bachelor pad but obviously
it wasn't because in later seasons we
would go to the bachelor mansion and
that would definitely become the
ultimate bachelor pad
[Music]
but as much as that house Mansion pad
wasn't that sheet it is the ultimate
bachelor pad
the first bachelor was a graduate of not
only Harvard but Stanford as well
don't drink for every I believe degree
this guy has graduating from Harvard he
attended Stanford University
it's only two but any excuse okay Chris
Harrison keeps saying which I think is
kind of fun like big things that were
happening when the shows came out so if
the bachelor came out in 2002 I was
gonna ask you JC and Chris Ann like
where were you in 2002 I was doing
theater Oh VC was doing theater me too
okay we were doing theater not much has
changed
trying to find a quality man is like
trying to find a needle in a haystack
and look at these audition tapes you
guys I don't know if they still do
audition tapes actually but if they do I
mean anybody can you know without their
iPhone in film one back in these days
this is when you you've found a friend
and you were like do you have a
camcorder
does anybody have a digital camera with
video capability thank you and again we
are gonna drink for everything that's a
little bit different we still had limos
that was still the same but we had a
little limo driver character who's that
guy don't drink for every time you saw
the limo driver
now why did they get rid of the limo
driver because these days everybody
opens the doors for themselves I think
the answer can actually be found here in
this night one footage you see a woman
named Kim get out and the limo drivers
face he's just like yikes I feel like
he's looking at her and thinking what
are you doing
hi Alex I'm Shannon so we're meeting
some of the women and like the show
talks about sex now certainly but I
guess I assume that back in the day
didn't necessarily get into it no no no
we meet Amanda and find out she's
purchased a trapeze the craziest things
I've ever done was purchase a trapeze I
don't even really know what that means
for some entertainment oh and then
there's Trista first impression of the
bachelor is definitely a good one
but let's do it now don't drink for
everything fame we had someone give Alex
a gift on night one for dummies there
are a ton of candles on don't ring for
every candle
Chris Harrison came in and did a little
kin jig on the champagne glass to signal
the rose ceremony because yes there were
rose ceremonies Amanda and a man to the
trapeze artist gets the first rose and
spoiler alert she is two outs of pick in
the end so oh my gosh the first rose is
always very indicative of who a strong
initial attraction is to in that initial
direction also last song in fact we will
see later in the episode the Trista gave
her first rose to Ryan and guess what he
used to she chose in the end iron these
are a lot of spoiler alerts but also
it's like these first seasons were
spoiler alerts for the whole franchise
because so much of the stuff that they
did stuck around
[Applause]
babe I want to tell you please drink
responsibly because the drinking games
on this episode are insane be a grown-up
put on your oversized blazer and get
ready don't drink
for every franchise first we had the
first group date who is that guy and
what did he do to get those five women
the first time thankfully we still have
the same host we have ceremony gosh and
there's more right from the first season
women cried as they left this is harder
than I thought it would be and Chris
Harrison said take a moment goodbye take
a moment and say your goodbyes and the
first and then and then and it was oh
the first season of The Bachelor was
very chic everybody
we started strong if we see some whales
we should watch and first ambulance
everything tiny
there's too many too many firsts too
many things too much iconic pop culture
too many it's unforgettable okay got it
[Applause]
I can't get over this I truly thought
that the franchise had started off a
little more tame and build up the drama
over the years no no no season one we
called an ambulance on someone I was so
certain I was not going to cry on
national TV so we catched up with Rhonda
who was the first ambulance freaked out
and with Bloomie's who was the first
kiss it was a wonderful experience I
grew so much but it definitely hit us
like a ton of bricks so we lift our
glass we lift up the Trailblazers of the
franchise ladies thank you we applaud
you we have a drink to you some of the
questions that you asked I'm not gonna
answer right and some of the things you
may want to do it's not gonna happen
what was also really interesting was
that we even had similar dating issues
back then a woman named Shannon did it
want to get as physical as Alex the
bachelor necessarily did as soon and
speaking of the first fantasy suite was
a deluxe deluxe Chalet ultimately I
think we have Shannon Amanda and Trista
and we don't really know much about
Amanda other than the trapeze thing
first of entertainment but Shannon is
the one sent home which gives us our
first iconic bayy
Alex eliminates Shannon you accept this
rose yes so he walks her out but just
like Shannon wanted they are not
touching
it's like stone face like and they're
walking out and not touching and I'm
thinking is this gonna be it and then
Alex literally kind of whispers to her
we're gonna stop at this bench right
here and I think it was kind of a
production cue it seemed to be but he
was telling her I don't know really for
this show we have just stop and we like
talk before you go
but they shake an and she leaves and
then she turns around
[Music]
and we will raise our glass to this
being the first dumpee who wanted we're
just curious why we are two different
people at different parts in our life
and we we I think we'll struggle with
each other too much what did you think
of Alex's explanation I thought it was
solid but Shannon did not so cheers to
our first just dumped limo rant I think
that Alex is weak I scared him because
I'm not going to sit back and say okay
Alex whatever you want but yeah this
show was sexier than I thought it was
going to be in the beginning we are now
back to Amanda don't drink for her
talking about every cosplay outfit she
owns I loved Wonder Woman I thought she
was the coolest thing I also loved
Wonder Woman I have a costume that is
good news for every deep makeout sesh
once we open the envelope we practically
ran out of that restaurant back to the
hotel
and then for every night vision moment
in the fantasy suite
I couldn't believe this you guys they
used to have cameras in the fantasy
suite
that's not allowed that's not okay
I don't want this black and white
Instagram filter footage get it away
jacy's stop it you stop it stop doing
this to me you know but I do think a man
too gave him our first I'm falling in
love with him and oh gosh we've still
gotta meet Trista
hi Alex nice to meet you I'm Krista but
let's fly through meeting Trista because
we're going to talk about her more when
she is the Bachelorette so we get our
first travel I think we went to Hawaii
we get our first incident of someone
being ill
and our first incident of like a
stay-at-home date where you have to show
how great of a person you are by like
hanging out with that sick person also
don't drink for every time Chris
Harrison says will we or won't we talk
to Alex and Michelle Mitchell what is
Alex Michelle hopefully we will catch up
with him tonight
Alex join me for a highly anticipated
interview and what about Alex himself
I still haven't spilled wine and I'm
Chris Harrison's blazer so that's great
but Alex Michelle is picking his
engagement ring and it's not me Elaine I
can take a look at some rings huh that
is exactly what I'm looking for
I miss Neil where's Neil
it doesn't feel right without Neil right
who's this lady so Alex dumbs Trista all
right I hope that we can be friends and
what did you think of the goodbye I
found it to be a bit unceremonious Alex
did not seem super emotionally
distraught to me but let me know in the
comments below and you know alex is
talking about Amanda Andy says and I
quote that one of the reasons he is so
into her is that she makes him feel good
she makes me feel good
[Music]
not a lot of depth there okay and then
the biggest shock of all this ring I'm
gonna hold onto it
let me explain why oh my gosh you guys I
did not realize that on the very first
season of The Bachelor there wasn't an
engagement he picked out a ring and then
he kind of showed it to a man I was like
I got this ring but the thing is I don't
want to give it to you can you we like
I'm still babe I love it if you would
move to California so you should be
together
what did you guys think of the first
season of the bachelors finale
ultimately spoiler alert Amanda and Alex
are not together anymore and the show
did not find Alex we have tried to get
ahold of Alex Michelle for years we've
not been able to Chris Harrison said
that he turned them down for interviews
so we don't know what Alex is doing here
she is our Bachelorette but now we're
gonna get to a real love story something
that really fit so I'm gonna get into
the right fit
[Music]
it's the og Bachelorette look of course
spoiler alert
we know that Trista Sutter ended up with
Ryan a firefighter on her season and I
got goose bumps when they first met each
other how are you really good nice to
meet you
did you guys let me know in the comments
below
there's some things I did like about
this season as we got to know the guys
for some reason we went to their real
houses and that's my place right there
like there's Greg the musician and don't
tell me that booboo wasn't trying to get
famous by being on this show Greg the
musician walked so gen-y Congrats so we
are in Greg's apartment in New York and
I don't know what's happening tryst is
like can you get me some water and
actually like
sure and that seems to be a real
struggle like don't drink for the whole
time he's just trying to get her a glass
of water poor Greg he didn't seem to do
a very good cleanup job before you left
for filming like is that a towel over a
cardboard box is happening I do think
that part of bachelor/bachelorette
should be oh you go back to that
person's apartment you see their real
life a real house what do you think let
me know in the comments below
very telling about Greg we're talking
house you seemed to have a mouth is
there a mouth or something years ago but
then right when we're feeling a little
bit of trauma they put in cities with a
Bachelor quarantine check-in it's time
again for a bachelor in quarantine check
in oh but this week it's gonna rub this
with casseon off and she's just broken
up with Colton Underwood thanks for
being here I really appreciate it
excited so yeah Cassie's here looking
fabulous by the way she seems to have
agreed to do this interview but she
doesn't even want to talk that much
about her and Colton don't drink every
time she said she didn't want to get
into the specifics love their breakup
don't know if I want to talk all about
the breakup at all you know it's kind of
like a sensitive subject and we haven't
really talked about it publicly yet I
don't know if either of this is ready
again I don't really want to go into
detail about anything I look I adore
both Cassie and Colton they've always
both been lovely to me and I wish them
both the best so whatever happened
hopefully they can move forward
positively and supportively and thank
you dressed up here I am not knowing
where I stand here I am looking for a
place to land so we're really digging
into Trista and Ryan love story
I knew Ryan was a firefighter but I did
not
wit that he was a poet yes don't drink
for every beautiful romantic poem II
wrote to tres top part in the palm of
her hand a boy dying to be her man
she is the rainbow through the rain she
is to me they laughed her through the
pain but look again I don't really know
what's happening on these seasons long
story short we're at the finale and
don't drink do not drink absolutely do
not have even a sip for every petal you
see what's happening
so Ryan is proposing they get engaged we
cut to the full wedding they got married
on TV I mean like 20 million people
watched 20 million viewers and by the
way that is not Chris Harrison I'll be
honest I asked him about this and he
told me at the time they just hadn't
even considered like Oh Chris should get
ordained and marry them
so our final first is the wedding Trista
and Ryan were our first bachelor
bachelorette franchise wedding and uh
they are still married today Trista said
she wanted a boy and a girl they did
that hey Blake sirs hey peanut he said
hey penis
she wanted kids in a beautiful life they
did that and we catch up with them and
she's crying
I hope you realize how much I appreciate
you oh it was amazing you guys they were
love her fixed thing just like this wine
is fitting well to my face and let me
know in the comments below what you
thought of this episode I truly loved
the trip down memory lane that was
familiar yet surprising because I know
the franchise but I didn't watch these
seasons it was so fun to watch love to
hear you guys his thoughts as always
[Music]
everybody be your own Sheikh be your own
fit and raise a glass to yourself you
guys they love you so much thank you for
watching I am on Twitter tik-tok
Instagram and cameo if you want a
personal message from me JC and
Christine are here in their early 2000s
where and we are so happy to continue we
will be back with another episode of The
Bachelor grade is seasons ever you know
what the more you drink the less wines
in there and so you're not gonna spill
as much hmm oh I spilled some but I'm a
pants oh I suppose again
[Music]